Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in the chapter of
vigilance and awareness, hyper awareness
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala's
observation.
this is the fifth chapter
in
authored by of Abu Zakaria.
He mentions the first narration
which many of us are familiar with.
What is Omar's
Omar's
huh
now that's his that's his
what year did he pass away? Did he was
he martyed?
Oh, how different the world would be if
it were 23 now.
Close. Only 10 years off.
Which
10 years off? 13. 13.
we have Abu Bakr
had two and some years.
Then
took the mantle and for 10 very strong
years he expanded
the Muslim empire in a way that was
exponential and permanent.
Narrates that the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam had an interaction with
a man who was a very strange man. He
says,
[Silence]
Wasam.
Islam.
Omar says, "As we were once sitting in
with the messenger of Allah sallaiam
meaning in the masid, a man entered and
came upon us.
He was
very he had on very white clothing
and it contrasted sharply with his jet
black hair.
[Arabic recitation]
Yet he did not have the appearance of a
traveler.
So this is extremely strange. First of
all, having a white on that is that
clean in the desert is almost
impossible,
right? the desert is a very harsh
environment. It bakes clothing and the
sand and dirt and so on and so forth.
It's very hard to keep anything very
white and clean in that way. And his
hair was very black that contrasted very
sharply with his very white clothing.
And none of us recognized him yet. He
didn't have the traces of travel on him,
the hallmarks of a traveler.
Now, as we'll find out later, and as I
think we all know, this was
But the question is, why did he come in
this form?
Why this form?
Huh?
Well, yes, he came for that purpose, but
why this form?
Son of Huh?
[Silence]
If we saw someone walk in right now, I
want you to imagine yourself sitting
there.
You're sitting with the messenger of
Allah Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam.
It's going to take a lot to get your
attention away from him. You watch this
man speak to trees and rocks.
You've seen him
split the moon.
He recites the words of Allah.
If you're sitting in front of that man,
is it going to be, you know, looking all
around, very easy to distract you, or
are you going to be hyperfocused on him?
of course hyperfocused.
It takes a lot to get them to draw away
their attention from him right now.
Imagine if we were sitting in such a
gathering and someone walked in that
none of us recognized
and had the most black hair you've ever
seen with the most white billowing
clothing.
And it contrasted so sharply that it
almost scares you, right?
What what would be our reaction?
All eyes would be on that person. It is
to draw all attention to him and to not
just well this is run-of-the-mill.
People always come and ask the prophet
stuff. Sallallah.aii wasallam. And
usually the desert men, the bedins, they
don't have the most sophisticated
questions. Okay? They're asking very
simple stuff. Seasoned companions like,
of course, they'll listen, but they know
the answers to a lot of these things.
But when someone this walks in now,
everybody is staring at this person and
everything he says we're going to
memorize as well. Because half of this
narration is what Gibl says. It's not
just what the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said because what is knowledge?
Knowledge is two halves. The first half
is a question. The second half is the
correct answer. That's what knowledge
is. And so gi comes in this form in
order to draw everyone's attention to be
not only hyperfocused on the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam but also
hyperfocused on everything that he says
because they don't know this is gi this
is just a very bizarre person that just
walked in the masid, right? and he
speaks weird and he looks weird and so
they are not just listening to hear what
the prophet says they are listening to
hear what this guy is saying too and
that's important because what Gibrel
says is half of the information
so
he says he continued to walk forward
until he sat to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sat to him so close that
he was able to position his knees to the
knees of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Imagine how
here or how he's sitting right if I were
sitting that way and he came very close
and our knees were touching right in
that posture as if you're in that is the
posture they were in not necessarily
this is here this is called this this
sitting position the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam sometimes sat that
after salah. He sat
but usually he would also sit in this
kind of jel right and so he came very
close and he sat very close to him. Now
everything Gibl is doing is part of the
is part of our religion. Okay. So the
way that he is seeking the knowledge
from the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam is
part of the religion. Jirel is not only
teaching us what is Islam and what is
iman and what isan. He's also teaching
us how do we ask these questions and
where do we sit and how do we position
ourselves. Imagine if someone came in
and you know instead of sitting in front
of the person of knowledge to study
they sit off at the wall say hey I got a
question all the way over there it seems
what it's inappropriate how do we seek
knowledge and this is something that is
almost a lost sunnah what is a lost
sunnah the way that people sit in Juma
because of the lines in the carpet,
right? Most of the masid is looking at
the wall.
That's not how they used to sit around
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam.
Everyone would face the meim. They would
not sit in lines in front of him.
Sallallam.
They would come in and muster together
and everyone is facing towards the
member around the prophet sallall.aii.
Wasam
then when the time of salah came they
would stand up and then make their rose.
But people are most usually drawn to
sitting in a very awkward way when they
sit to seek knowledge because in part
because of the lines. Right? So if you
notice this row here most people are
facing this way. The
proper way of seeking knowledge is that
a person faces the
scholar or faces here the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam and comes close
comes close. He was so close that his
knees were to his knees. This is part of
what this is part of the religion
because seeking knowledge has a key.
Seeking knowledge has a key. What is the
key of seeking knowledge? Who can tell
us?
I want you to imagine knowledge is in
the chests of men. Men who have it.
People of knowledge, men of knowledge.
Knowledge is locked up in their chest.
You have to get it out of them. What's
the key to get accessing that knowledge?
Huh? Question. No.
[Arabic recitation]
El
good and high levels of etiquette.
If you see a person who's very
knowledgeable, you are looking at a
person who has a mastered alab
because the only way you can access that
knowledge from the chest of men is if
they give it to you and the only way
they will give it to you is if you have
the proper adep
one of his greatest teachers is whollah
Correct.
Went to meet Imik
when he was 14.
14 years old. Do not imagine the 14 year
olds that are running around today.
14 back then was age of marriage, age of
going to battle, people who had started
living as an adult by all intents and
purposes. But I
he did not go to meet Alik even though
he was in Mecca since he was an infant.
He could have gone a lot earlier but he
didn't go until he had memorized al
because he's going to meet Malik
and Malik authored a book already called
Mu.
How bad how poor mannered would he be if
he showed up saying I want knowledge but
you haven't you haven't even studied
what I've already put out what you
already had access to so he committed to
memory then he came to meet Malik
said that when he would sit in the
gathering of Malik in the presence of
Malik he would
very quietly turned the page in his book
because it was bad manners to make a
sound with the page in front of Malik.
Can you imagine that? That this is bad
manners. Now you're turning turning the
book. What are you in a hurry? Right.
You're disturbing me with with the
pages. No, she was so hypervigilant
of his with
that he would take care not to make a
sound when he turned the page in the
book
is the key to knowledge. What's the
evidence?
Allah says that if it is said to you
stand.
This this was revealed regarding the way
that they would muster and sit around
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. They
were reluctant
to let someone into their gathering.
They were locked up around him. And if
someone came in, they were reluctant to
let him in because they don't want to
lose their spot. Right? And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said, "If it is said
to you, make room in the majice, make
room. And if it's said to you, stand up,
stand up. Allah will raise
those amongst you who believe and those
who were given knowledge
a peg higher than the average believer.
So this is what this is.
It was said
[Silence]
It was said that knowledge used to be in
the hearts of men,
the earlier scholars, the ancient
scholars, the first century, second
century after Hijra, no one can reach
that level. It is almost impossible.
Maybe once in a hundred years someone
could reach the level of that kind of
knowledge.
However, over time knowledge
transitioned from the hearts of men into
the depths of books and the keys
remained in the hearts of men. In order
to access it, you have to have fine high
levels of etiquette
because yes, a scholar could give you an
answer to your question. Is this halal?
Yes, that's it. That's all you're
getting. You're getting the bare minimum
unless you find a way to get him to
bring out the extras, bring out the
dressings, bring out the additions,
bring out the extra that is only
accessed
with any human being by getting on their
good side. Right? And so part of our
religion that Gibl is teaching us in
this narration is how we adorn
ourselves with the etiquette before we
even ask the question
and
Subhanahu
subalamu.